نحن الان متواجدين على مفترق ابو هولي
الرئيسي على شارع صلاح الدين الواصل ما
بين محافظات جنوب قطاع غزه وشمال قطاع غزه
حيث انسحاب شبه كامل من هذه المنطقه وهذا
المحور للدبابات الاسرائيليه التي كانت
هنا متواجده منذ عده ايام على المحور
الجنوبي لمدينه دير البلح حيث هنا خاضت
المقاومه الفلسطينيه اشتباكات عنيفه
بالاضافه الى تدمير واسع كما نش هد في هذه
الاثناء خلفته الدبابات الاسرائيليه دمار
ما فيش يعني فيش معالم للارض يعني ما فيش
ولا معالم لبيت ولا لارض ولا لاي شيء مش
يعني متغيره كل معالم المنطقه الاحتلال
انسحب من هذ المنطقه انسحب على الحدود
يعني موجود بس في المنطقه في الداخل لا مش
موجود في الداخل هنا جسر القرار الرئيسي
بالاضافه الى مركز شرطه القراره هنا
المعروف في المنطقه القوات الاسرائيليه
خلفت دمارا كبيرا في هذه المنطقه وفي في
ممتلكات المواطنين والبنيه التحتيه اما
هذه المستوصف الطبي هو مستوصف مسقط لوزاره
الصحه دمرته ايضا القوات الاسرائيليه بشكل
كامل بعد ان خلف دمارا كبيرا وواسعا في
ممتلكات المواطنين والبنيه التحتيه الجيش
الاسرائيلي ينسحب من مناطق جنوب دير البلح
وايضا من شمال محافظه خانيونس جنوب القطاع
حيث وصلنا في هذه الاوقات الى منطقه جسر
القراره الرئيسي هنا بالقرب من مركز شرطه
القراره حيث شاهدنا الدمار الكبير التي
خلفته القوات الاسرائيليه المتوغلة
دبابات في كمائن محكمه وعمليات اطلاق
قذائف ايضا مضاده للدبابات هذه الاجزاء من
الاليات الاسرائيليه التي دمرتها الفصائل
الفلسطينيه خلال عمليه التوغل والتصدي
للاليات الاسرائيليه في هذه المنطقه وهذه
ايضا مخلفات بعض الجنود الاسرائيليين
وملابس الجنود الاسرائيليين الذين يعني
انسحبوا من هذه المنطقه خلال الوقت القريب
حتى المواطنين اغتنموا عدد من الحاجيات
التي تركها الاحتلال الاسرائيلي هنا على
شارع صلاح الدين ايضا حيث بدا يعود
المواطنين الى اماكن سكناهم التي خرجوا
منها بان دخول القوات الاسرائيليه الى هذه
المنطقه على ما يبدو بان هناك ايضا ما
زالت عمليه تموضع للدبابات وعدم انسحاب
كامل في
المنطقه الشرقيه لمدينه دير البلح في هذا
الاثناء نستمع لاصوات انفجارات كبيره جدا
وفي هذه الاثناء القوات الاسرائيليه ايضا
تقوم بعمليات تفجير لمنازل المواطنين في
المناطق شماليه لمحافظه خان يونس
وبالتحديد في منطقه القراره هذا الانفجار
الكبير الذي حدث للتو فقط في هذا المحور
حيث الدخان يتصاعد في هذه الاثناء من
منطقه محيط شارع اثنين مقابل مركز شرطه
القراره اشرف ابو عمره لقناه الجزيره
منطقه القراره محافظه خانيونس جنوب قطاع
غزه